do you think the censorship of trump is
working to actually
have people talk about it less
oh yeah
talk about trump less talk about trump i
think it is kind of working
i think trump chose to kind of back off
for for a couple months that's the scary
thing about censorship is it does work
it can work in an isolated system
so within the mainstream media network
the big tech social media network i mean
yeah you can stamp it out of those but
then you know it it still has a life
outside of there but it can be hidden
i don't think censorship works it's not
true donald trump just wasn't doing
anything for a few months he was just
playing golf then he started sending out
emails again and then all sudden they
kept talking about again and even when
trump wasn't saying things they were
still talking about trump nonstop they
were impeaching the guy
they are the ones who don't want him to
let him go now trump launched from the
desk of donald trump and then people
have created social media accounts that
are just reposting what trump is posting
on his own site and twitter's banning
them all yeah probably because we're in
a less isolated environment now with the
internet because like
the romans when they conquered the gauls
this guy versus generics like they just
basically stamped that all record of
those people they they censored it away
and tartaria and all this ancient asian
cultures that are just we don't even
know what they are because they were
erased let's let's clarify something
real quick
when people say that censorship works
and you look at how it affects modern
political discourse
it works in the sense that you hide
certain things but it doesn't make them
go away so what has the the the the the
tensions between the culture war
has it stopped no it's gotten
substantially worse but they banned all
these right-wing individuals and these
conservatives these trump supporters
yeah well they still exist and they
still believe things what happened was
these journalists are sitting on twitter
rocking back and forth like scratching
their head until their skin until
they're bleeding and then finally
twitter says we banned those people and
they go
they're gone they're finally gone and
they're just literally still sitting
there it's just all twitter did was like
pull down the blinds
they're literally still there no you can
feel the cultural tension building up
because of all this stuff
so
it's the the pressure cooker is
pressure cooker's on max yeah
that's me worried man that's why i was
like that's why when you were talking
about life boats i thought about the gun
and crowder yeah
the key is i think when you look at this
nietzsche quote you really let it seep
into you if you stare at the problem all
day it will you will become part of the
problem you have to to not i mean it's
good to know what the problem is but you
gotta find a solution i don't uh i don't
think it means you will be commenting be
careful that you you don't some great
people can probably stare into it their
entire life and not become the demon but
i think there's a tendency too
so you know this alaska airline thing
really unsettled me because it reminded
me not of 1984 which is technically
fiction but of actual historical events
like during the soviet union up those
nice people who just silently sat by
while their neighbors were rounded up
they didn't want to think about politics
they just wanted to go about their day
and then they would turn in their own
neighbors this is what gina carrano got
in trouble for she was right i just
heard um a number that said that in the
soviet union two and five people were
informants for the state yes that meant
that somebody in your family was an
informant and you couldn't talk about
anything so you'll talk about censorship
working get people in your family
involved on the government payroll see
you know why they had to round people up
and send them to gulagzian
because a censorship wasn't working
that's true they had shut down any
anti-state media
out it was all propaganda but people
still
were talking and spreading information
and then these informants would go to
the state and be alike did you hear they
were just saying these things all right
well censoring isn't working send them
to the gulag
gotta excise them from sight was the
only way because when you when when you
cut out a man's tongue you're not
proving him wrong you're only proving
you are scared of what you might say
that's a game with i'm pretty sure it's
a game of thrones quotes
what's the character uh tyrion yeah yeah
i thought
i thought you were saying today in your
in your video about contra points was
really interesting how you know sort of
the left is calling out the free speech
warriors
and the right is calling out the social
justice warriors but realistically
it's
i think that those two things do exist
and they're sort of both hypocritical on
both sides but then there are elements
of the right and left and center who are
more nuanced and i think that that's
where we all hope that we sit but it's
like
the
i think that both sides are right to a
certain degree sure sure but you look at
the new york times data they recently
did this thing where they said
38 of democrats are in a bubble
surrounded only by democrats no exposure
to conservatives but it's something like
19 of republicans are in a bubble with
no exposure to democrats so that means
that there are conservatives
who overlap
conservatives are less likely to be in a
bubble and not understand democrats it
makes sense because the the old saying
is that uh conservatives think liberals
are misguided but liberals think
conservatives are evil to your point
here's what we see
there is
a rule
when you in the culture where when you
look at the left that when a
conservative gets censored they laugh
they gloat and they celebrate
then you will see the rule on the right
that people will immediately defend the
conservatives who get censored
when the leftists get censored it is a
rule that they will scream it is unfair
at censorship and the conservatives are
claiming they're the ones getting banned
and it is still a rule that
conservatives will defend the left when
they get censored
so
when the left gets censored the right
and the left scream censorship is wrong
when the right gets censored the left
laughs and mocks the right and the right
says this is wrong you don't think there
are elements of the right that laugh
when people on the left get banned
because they think it's like karma
that's different yeah so it's one thing
when the left says dude facebook's a
private business if they want to ban you
they're allowed to and then a
conservative goes
you got banned i thought you said it was
a private business serves you right
there's a difference
but there are people on the right that's
why i said it's it's uh
the exception on the left are those who
would defend a conservative when they're
censored and the exception on the right
is those who would mock the left when
they got censored yeah i think that's a
good ratio and then there's the
disaffected liberals and moderates who
are pretty principled straight through
i mean the reality is that it's hard to
defend free speech in an absolute sense
it's because you're put into a position
where you're defending horrible ideas
it's like this burden that you have to
carry around i constantly feel that but
you have to just keep walking
because
we we don't have anything other than our
principles but then you know i'm not
even going to claim to be perfect
because there are exceptions you know
there are exceptions which is the harsh
reality
you know legality there's legality and
then there's free speech in the pure
philosophical sense there's law and
there's philosophy it's it's interesting
in that we didn't necessarily have to
deal with a lot of the creepy stuff on
the internet when it came to public
discourse
like
you know people would go out in the
street and they'd show pictures of like
dead fetuses and stuff
and but for the most part you don't have
people walking around with
you know holding up big signs with like
pornography and stuff on it now on
social media people can just spam a
button and flood a network with garbage
and crap
and that makes it really difficult for
for regular people to engage in a
platform and have this kind of speech
when they're drowned out i suppose in
reality though
the the issue might actually just be
anonymity
and or
a lack of proximity
why won't someone show up to city hall
carrying you know big posters of you
know pornography
uh because they'd have to be there
holding it themselves and then people
would see them and judge them and they'd
feel bad and be worried about their
access to resources
when it comes to social media they use
an anime avatar or you know a cat person
or something and then they can post
whatever they want no one knows who they
are right but the paradox is that when
you're anonymous you feel the true
freedom to express what you want to say
because that's exactly what i'm saying
yeah yeah so people post weirdo pictures
and creepy nonsense and garbage and they
flood the zone with
trash but so so it's simultaneously the
problem but it's also what gives us free
speech because when you have anonymity
like yeah it causes people to go crazy
and like spam with like crazy insane
stuff but it also is like a very
important fundamental human right like
arguably if you have a totalitarian
government and you need to you know
organize uh a response to it and you if
you do it if they know who you are
you're dead yeah but if you have
anonymity you can do it functionally
yeah like when antifa went out and
burned down
burn set fire to vehicles and threw
bricks through windows and the cops
couldn't do anything about it because
they were all wearing masks exactly it's
true but i was thinking more about the
arab spring but yes for good or ill you
can organize safely with anonymity i'm
into every the history is written by the
victors man uh that
in in these countries where they have
these revolutions
when the when the revolution wins the
revolutionaries are the good guys if
they lose they were insurgent terrorists
and they were suppressed except for
castro because we had media now we have
tv and radio so we can remember how uh
what was that guy's name shay guevara
putting the bullet in the guy's head or
the girl's head that image you ever see
that shake over image we're like we love
shagwaver people wear his shirt a shirt
with his face on it he was a psychotic
murderer i mean he was a murderer he was
he was a cold-blooded murderer but the
motorcycle diaries was a sick movie
is that about him yeah
it's actually a good movie so there are
the history is written by the victors
but maybe the victors were the ones that
built the internet yeah but listen to uh
uh we have history of shea being a bad
person because we aren't socialists
because our our government was
anti-socialist so we made sure that that
kind of stuff existed
but
history is written by the victors man if
the activists win it was it was funny
what did uh
jack bosobic tweeted today will be
called like what is it called the age of
dumb yeah
and um and i said
yeah but if the left wins it'll be
called the age of new enlightenment
it'll be the great awakening the great
awokening when people finally realized
what was truly happening
that's what that's what it'll be
but where are the history books what
what what are going to be the history
i know but in a thousand years what are
people actually going to reference
what do you mean like wikipedia that or
something more immutable potentially
like a blockchain or databases that
can't be tampered with right or if you
see them tampered with you know they
were tampered with exactly i don't i i
disagree i mean there will be both we're
going to exist in both worlds there's
going to be encyclopedias on you know
that are immutable and then there's
going to be ones that are controlled by
centralized authorities
yeah but the centralized authorities for
now control the dominant narrative it's
interesting though uh you know i like
that that phrase if if uh if if the
situation was hopeless the propaganda
wouldn't be necessary
and
i mean uh
among my three channels we get you know
i think 50 to 60 million views per month
it's down a bit because i used to do
three more segments every day i cut
those out and i cut off weekends but
we're still hitting around 50 million
and so it's not the same as you know cnn
on youtube gets 200 million but i think
that's pretty good about that
the net videos over the course of your
life because you'll live longer because
you're wrestling a little bit more
you'll still put out the same kind of
guys no
the idea is to build something and
expand and get other people you know
empower other people to start doing
similar things like this and so i think
there's some optimism there that a show
like this can exist the problem is
they've been going after steven crowder
like crazy and it's never it's it's it's
not for legitimate things so you know
crowder has one of the biggest i i guess
we can call it counter culture shows
he is a conservative personality very
funny with millions of fans and
subscribers and
uh
he challenges the establishment he you
know and he questions the official
narratives and so what do they go after
them for
out of context uh edgy jokes or just
edgy jokes in general or they just make
things up like when he was quoting cdc
data they said oh that's misinformation
so they take his videos down and then
they boot him from the partner program
so they're trying really hard to it's a
culture war man how much does it cost to
launch a network channel
do you think
what do you mean in terms of getting
like a channel on
you know
tv
i don't know um
let me think
i don't think it's that much maybe 20 to
50 million something for the alternative
media to consider but why do you want to
be on tv i don't know because maybe
maybe it's not even that much to be
honest yeah i would be that's why i'm
asking it might not be worth it but i
think at this point it's probably dirt
because what's the point
yeah
well the point is that i think there are
millions of people who are still
in that world that like the newer
generation is not in that world but the
you know i don't know what the numbers
are
i think uh
a lot of people are are watching
digitally tv ratings are in the gutter
and we are going to see in the next five
to ten years a major switch to to
digital who controls
like getting a channel
it's it's it's the and you negotiate
with the providers so like you would go
to comcast and then say we want our
channel to be on your you know list
right and then you'd work out a deal and
typically how it works is like they give
you a few cents per household or
whatever so you use a lot of money for
for some of these channels but then you
got to produce content and so a lot of
what we're seeing now is this is amazing
mtv for instance they just do reruns of
ridiculousness
i love it viceland or vice tv or
whatever they're calling it these days
vice was supposed to have their own
cable channel and they finally got it
they just started doing reruns of movies
you'd like turn on vice and it would be
like you know groundhog day's on yeah
that's a good example of
it not being worth it to get a channel
because vice did it and it's not
particularly effective and no one's
gonna watch it no one's gonna watch it
two in the morning or four in the
morning so like what's the point of all
that dead space well yeah tv doesn't
work like you can't just pull up you
know go through the channels on your
phone i would think that they would the
providers would start to do that so that
you could just everything
everything's on demand now right so hulu
is way more
relevant than cable tv mm-hmm so if i
want to watch star trek i just go to
netflix or hulu i have an opportunity to
do like a radio show they were like hey
you want to let's do this video it's
going to air at 8 00 p.m on tuesday and
i was like okay so it ran once on 8 pm
on tuesday and it was never you can't
get it it was and it felt so like i was
robbed like i spent all this time
recording this thing that is not now
persistent on the internet like as a
youtube video that someone can click on
the value of it being there all the time
transcends magnitudes more value than
waiting until 9 pm to see a show i
wonder if this is all the great filter
you know the great filter
you know fermi's paradox vaguely you're
familiar with no yeah so the idea being
you know if uh the universe is so vast
then surely there's intelligent life if
there is how we haven't seen any signs
of it and there's a bunch of hypotheses
about why it may be and the great filter
is one of them and that's when a
civilization reaches a certain point and
they just get filtered out of existence
right something happens to intelligent
species that they wipe themselves out
and i'm thinking like everything we're
looking at right now
um maybe it's like yeast in a in a
bottle you know just eating the sugars
and farting ourselves to death but in
reference to what you're saying about
youtube and stuff maybe it's just that
we have billions of hours of content
every single day every perspective and
at a certain point there's just too much
static it's it's like there was a period
where
everything was noise it was chaos then
we built upon it this civilization this
order and then continuing our expansion
of technology it's going back to static
to noise you know if you were to
actually look at the raw feed of youtube
like the fire hose of all the videos
being uploaded i bet it's nonsensical
gibberish and garbage
it's like a seven second video of like a
chicken looking at a camera and then a
hamster just walking around then there's
like some little kid staying at the
camera confused for three minutes and
then the family it's just a whole bunch
of nonsense no one ever sees right but
at this
it's both i mean we also have so much
access like i feel like i learn faster
than i used to
i do probably not when i was a baby like
you know you learn the most when you're
a baby but the amount of information
that we're getting now is the velocity
is so high that we're probably evolving
faster in certain ways as well i think
that baby things uh uh i'm not look
maybe it's true like scientists get a
baby i recommend it
hold on how long how long does it take a
baby to start speaking about a year a
year and
in what way do they start speaking in a
year
just sounds that vaguely resemble in in
i think they say on average in 44 weeks
to master a a romance language if you're
a germanic or romantic speaker and 88
weeks for an east asian language like
chinese
so in one year you can be fluent
in german or french a baby can mutter
somewhere we should do a show a
challenge of like a super smart person
versus a baby no i i'm learning a
language yeah for a year it's it's it's
not that you know people always say this
like oh it's so easy to pick up when
you're a kid well it's because you're
not doing anything also your brain is
lit up like they do studies fmri exams
on people with lsd and their entire
brains light up and they're active like
the right and the left hemisphere once
and that's how baby brains are
they haven't learned well they're trying
to filter stuff out trying to learn
learning
there's such high demand and need for
them to communicate because it's your
fir when it's your first language like
your body is forcing you to figure it
out so that you can achieve certain
things that you want to achieve which
you don't
have that need when you already know one
language that's not true
i mean depending on where you live yeah
maybe you move somewhere and you have to
exactly that's true and you'll pick up
the language supervision and so i was
reading it says on average it's 44 weeks
i don't know what this study was i read
it on reddit or something to master if
you speak a germanic or romance language
in 44 weeks you can be fluent in another
language if you are actively pursuing
and speaking and using that language
let's launch the study
well i mean i guess they're earning
changes
how long does it take for a child to get
to the point where they're having a
conversation like this probably
four
years old i mean yeah four years they
could be discussing discussing that the
nuance of economic policy probably the
smartest kid in the world i would argue
could keep up i think a smartest
four-year-old on the planet there you go
yeah like uh
10 or 11 maybe they're having a
conversation but mostly asking questions
due to their lack of exposure to
information and context so it's not an
issue of ability it's an issue of just
time yeah you know we've had more more
more time to to learn things and
understand i mean there are videos
there's one video of this uh
chinese boy playing chopin uh fantasy
impromptu he's three i'm telling you
this it's madness i mean it's probably
he's been trained by his parents in a
very
borderline abusive way i don't want to
accuse anything but
it's insane and that's something that
none of us could do and it might take a
decade to learn so
you know there are but that's the
exception let's get back to talking
about the apocalypse yeah we're talking
about how do we how do we start talking
about we're talking about yeast farting
itself to death in a right in a petri
dish and i think this mass influence of
information is causing interference in
our under in our ability so that's the
static is this weird influence in tide
pools what would happen is organisms
would live at one level of the tide pool
or vertically so petri dishes are kind
of one they're only two dimensional they
don't really have up and down you can't
really get out of it normally in a tide
pool if an area of the tide pool got too
acidic or too dangerous for these
organisms to live they would come
together and form a new type of organism
that could float up to a different
strata of the tide pool and essentially
evolve into a new organism collectively
they would come together and create a
new organism now in petri dishes you
don't see that because they're
two-dimensional they don't have anywhere
to go so they eat them they die but in
the tide pool our nature is to come
together form a new species essentially
and then move somewhere where we can
thrive thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you